لذلك أنا من بروكلين ، وهذا دائمًا
مهم حقًا بالنسبة لي
لأنني أعتقد أنه يقول الكثير عن
كيف أصبحت من أنا ، لذا فإن أول شيء في
حياتك بعد الانتخابات الرئاسية لعام 2016
كان حقًا مستضيفًا  من
Dave Chappelle and A Tribe Called Quest
كان الضيف الموسيقي نوعًا من
وسائل الإعلام السائدة ، كانت روايتك بعد
هذا العرض تتحدث حقًا عن أنك
تعرف هذا النوع من النقد السياسي ولكن
ما لم يتحدثوا عنه هو حقيقة
وجود  خمسة رجال مسلمين سود في
ليلة السبت لايف ديف شابيل علي
شهيد محمد و q-tip من الفحم
Quest Busta Rhymes والنتيجة
أنهم لم يتحدثوا عنهم
كمسلمين ليس لأن إسلامهم
مخفي لأنه ليس أنت  يعلمون ولكن
لأن إسلامهم يبدو
كما يفكرون طالما أنه يبدو كما
لو كنت تعتقد أنه قنبلة هل تعرف
شخصًا بني اللون غير مقتبس له
لحية لا يتحدث الإنجليزية ، فأنت
لا ترى قنبلة عندما  مهمة استوائية
استراح Grammys بشكل صحيح ، ولكن إذا كنت
تعلم جيدًا أنهم مجرد تاريخ
شكّل فيه المسلمون السود حقًا
الطرق التي يعمل بها الناس ويتنقلون
في العالم ، فقد ألهمتني حقًا مثل
Malcolm X ، على سبيل المثال ألهمت الناس
ليكونوا ملتزمين جدًا  إلى أسئلة
العدالة الاجتماعية
ثم ستراها وستراها طوال الوقت